[The Road to Health and Happiness]
[Produced by Dr. David Bennett Hill Salem, Oregon, A Bell & Howell Filmasound Library Release]
[Children are standing on the beach, in a line, holding hands. There is text over the picture.]
[Good health, long life and happiness are not accidents. To know how to live and apply it, greatly increases the capacity to work, to be happy and to be useful. It develops the body, the mind and the heart -- it enobles the man as a whole.]
[The road to abundant life is not hard to follow and it's not expensive. The most important rules are:]
[Good mental habits -- Contented mind, proper reading and entertainment, Sunday School and Church.]
[Two girls are seated at a table, one girl is reading. Two young boys are in front of the table.]
[The girl that is reading shows the book to the other children. The children gather next to her.]
[The same four children are seated on stools by the radio.]
["Thou wilt keep him in perfect peace, whose mind is stayed on Thee."]
[The outside of a traditional church with a steeple is shown.]
[People in nice clothing are shown walking up to the front door of the church. There are couples, singles, and families.]
[A man in a suit holds the door open for people to enter.]
[Cleanliness -- Wash hands and face at least three times daily. Bath, at least twice a week. Fresh garments.]
[A girl is washing up in the bathroom.]
[Fresh air -- the home, bedroom and school.]
[A girl wearing pajamas opens two windows in the bedroom of a house. There are curtains on the windows.]
[Sleep -- at least 10 hours.]
[The girl is awake in bed.]
[Comfortable clothing.]
[Five young girls wearing dresses are outside. Three of the girls remove their coats.]
[Exercise and Play.]
[Three older girls are on a tennis court. They separate and we see one girl facing the camera serving a tennis ball.]
[The girl hits the tennis ball back a few times. Another girl is shown hitting a tennis ball.]
[Four girls rollerskate toward the camera. Two are older and two are younger girls. One girl also has a dog on a leash.]
[Three older girls are playing with a ball. They are throwing it to each other.]
[Girls are shown swimming in a pool. Four girls are swimming toward the camera and some girls are sitting on the side of the pool.]
[Three girls smile at the camera as they swim towards it.]
[Three girls are lined up on a diving board. They each in turn dive into the pool.]
[Children are at the beach. A young boy leads a pony toward the camera. There is a young girl riding on the pony.]
[Nine children wearing bathing suits are walking down the beach in a line holding hands. There are other people on the beach and in the water in the background.]
[Four children holding hands are walking fast down the beach toward the camera. One is older, three are younger children. They are in silhouette with the sun setting behind them.]
[A boy is riding a bicycle on the beach.]
[Correct posture. Stand, sit and walk erect.]
[Girls are shown by the side of the pool. Three are standing and three are seated.]
[The girls that are standing turn around in a circle. They are all emphasizing correct posture.]
[Two younger girls who seem to be twins do back flips beside the pool. When done they then turn in complete circles.]
[Four older girls dressed in bathing suits are next to the pool. One is seated, three are standing. One of the girls standing is holding a ball over her head. The other two girls are holding baseball bats over their heads.]
[Six girls are seated in chairs next to the pool. All are dressed in bathing suits, four have swimming caps on. They are all looking at the camera and smiling.]
[Sunlight will help to keep you well and strong.]
[The six girls are shown at the pool again but now are lying down or seated on the concrete.]
[A group of six young boys and girls are at the beach seated on the sand.]
[A small black dog runs up to the center of the group and a girl pets him.]
[Children are playing on the beach. Two girls throw a beach ball back and forth.]
[Safety-first. All officers are a child's best friend and protector. Never speak of them otherwise.]
[City street scene. People are walking on the sidewalks, cars are in the street. A police officer is standing on the corner.]
[Three young girls approach the officer. He helps them across the busy road holding the youngest one in his arms and holding the hand of one of the other girls who are also holding hands.]
[The duties of the health department are education and prevention, providing pure water, pure food and correct sanitation.]
[Children are shown on the grounds of a school.]
[The class health record at the beginning of school.]
[Children and a teacher along with three other adults are in the classroom. There's a blackboard in front of the room that says "America the Beautiful" across the top.]
[The teacher is pointing to the chalkboard which says "First Day of School Sept. 13, 1937. Room Attendance 37 Health Examination 75% Dental Examination 80% Vaccination against Smallpox 60% Immunization against Diphtheria 75% Tuberculin Test 80%"]
[Some of the children are raising their hands.]
[The teacher goes over each category on the board.]
[Two weeks later. 100% room.]
[The teacher once again points to the chalkboard, with a date of Sept. 27, 1937. All the categories are now 100%.]
[The teacher points out each category.]
[The teacher and the students clap their hands and smile.]
[The teacher is at the front of the room pointing at the chalkboard. Two girls are standing with her. There's a table full of items next to them.]
[A sign is on the table that says "Food for the Growing Boys and Girls, Take Every Day." There is a plate of fruits and vegetables on the table along with bottles of milk.]
[A sign on the table says "Cereal" and a bowl of cereal is behind the sign.]
[Fruit is on a table and the sign in front of it says, "Fruit, canned or fresh, twice daily. Apples, oranges, peaches, pears, prunes, grapefruit, etc."]
[A hand holding a pointer points at each word on the sign.]
[As the pointer indicates the words, another person picks up each piece of fruit and the pointer points to that word]
[Butter pats are on a plate on the table. The sign says, "6 teaspoons of butter. 6 slices."]
[An egg is on a plate and the sign in front of it says, "1 egg."]
[A loaf of bread is on the table with a sign in front of it that says, "6 slices of bread." A person off-screen counts out six slices of bread.]
[A bottle of milk and four glasses of milk are on the table. The glasses have pictures of sailboats on them. The sign in front of it says, "One quart of milk. 4 glasses.]
[A person off-screen points at each glass of milk.]
[A pitcher of water is on the table. In front of it are 4 glasses full of water. The sign says "4 glasses of water."]
[Vegetables are on the table between two bottles. The sign in front of them says, "2 vegetables, twice daily. Tomatoes, lettuce, celery, carrots, cabbage, etc."]
[An off-screen person holds up each vegetable as it is pointed out on the sign.]
[A different sign is in front of the vegetables which says, "Meat, fish, chicken, liver, cheese, potatoes, and corn to satisfy the appetite."]
[Desserts are on plates on the table. The sign in front of it says, "Ice cream or puddings."]
[Two bottles are on the table with the labels to the side. One has a liquid in it and the other has pills in it. The sign in front of them says, "Cod liver oil, phosphate and calcium. For dosage consult your physician."]
[Medical Examination. The most reliable health advice is received from your family physician or health department.]
[A doctor is shown seated at a desk writing. There are two girls next to the desk. One is standing, the other is seated. A person off-screen holds a sign that says, "History and Record."]
[The doctor and the girls are talking to each other.]
[The doctor weighs the girls and measures their heights. A sign held by a person off-screen says, "Weight and measure."]
[The doctor administers an eye test to one of the girls while the other girl looks on. The girl reads the letters.]
[A sign is held up by a person off-screen which says, "Eyes."]
[The doctor puts a light on his forehead and looks up the nose of one of the girls while the other looks on. A sign says, "Nose."]
[The doctor uses a tongue depressor to look down the girl's throat. A sign held in front of the girl says, "Throat."]
[The doctor looks in the girl's ear. A sign says, "Ears."]
[The doctor taps on the girl's chest. A sign is held up that says, "Lungs and heart."]
[The doctor uses a stethoscope to listen to the girl's lungs and heart from the front.]
[The doctor goes around to the back of the girl and taps her several times on her back. He then listens to her lungs and heart with the stethoscope.]
[The girl breathes deeply as the doctor listens.]
[The girl is now lying down on a examination table. She is smiling, laughing and talking to the doctor. The other girl is behind her leaning on the table. The doctor is examining her abdomen.]
[The girl is sitting on the examination table and the doctor is testing her reflexes by tapping on her knee.]
[The doctor is examining the girl's feet. A sign is held up that says, "Feet."]
[The girl stands on the examination table while the doctor examines her feet.]
[The girl is seated while the doctor wipes her arm and gives her a vaccination. A sign says, "Vaccination against smallpox."]
[The doctor wipes her arm again and gives her a shot. A sign says, "Immunization against diptheria."]
[The doctor wipes her arm again and gives her a shot. A sign says "Tuberculin test."]
[Dental Examination. X-ray if needed. The most reliable advice and instruction on dentistry is received from your dentist. Children's teeth in all stages of decay should be filled or extracted.]
[The two girls are at the dentist's office. One girl is having her teeth examined by the dentist. The other girl is watching. There is also an female dental hygienist in the office assisting the dentist.]
[The dentist takes x-rays of the girl's teeth and hands them to the hygienist.]
[The dentist hands a mirror to the girl and is talking to her.]
[Brush five parts of each tooth from gum towards tooth; four tops, four outsides, four insides, four fronts, gums, cheeks and tongue. Use a good, small brush, good paste or powder, visit dentist twice yearly.]
[The dentist is brushing the girl's teeth. A sign is held up in front of them which says, "Brush two upper and two lower chewing surfaces."]
[While the dentist continues to brush the girl's teeth another sign is held up which says "Brush two upper and two lower outsides."]
[Another sign says "Brush two upper and two lower insides."]
[Continuing, another sign says "Brush two upper and two lower fronts."]
[Another sign is held up which says, "Brush gums, cheeks and tongue thoroughly."]
[The girl is handed a cup of water. A sign reads, "With water force suds vigorously between the teeth."]
[The dentist instructs her on how to use the water to help clean her teeth.]
[Another sign says "Develop bones and muscles of the face by chewing hard food and gum with mouth closed.]
[The girl is alone. She is smiling and a sign is held in fron of her which says, "The results, a pleasant smile and face for life."]
[The dentist has his fingers on a girl's lips pulling them away from her teeth. A sign is held up which says, "Irregularities of the teeth and deformed faces can be corrected."]
[A girl is shown seated in a chair next to the dentist. A model of teeth and gums is held up in front of the girl by a person off-screen.]
[Deformed face and, teeth age 12.]
[A young boy is seated in a dental chair. He is holding two books in front of him and a model of teeth and gums is on top of the books.]
[Close-up of the model of teeth and gums. The teeth are uneven.]
[Corrected, three years later.]
[The boy, now three years older, has had his teeth corrected. He sits in the chair with a new model of his teeth and gums. The teeth are now even.]
[Close-up of the model of teeth and gums. The teeth are now straight and even.]
[What orthodontia and dentistry have done for childhood has produced untold happiness and content where otherwise lives would have dragged on in mental and physical anguish.]
[At home, brush the teeth at least twice daily. The results, a beautiful smile and face for life.]
[A woman is brushing her teeth. A sign says, "Brush two upper and two lower chewing surfaces."]
[As the woman continues to brush signs are held in front of her, one after the other: "Brush two upper and two lower outsides."]
["Brush two upper and two lower insides."]
["Brush two upper and two lower fronts"]
["Brush gums, cheeks and tongue thoroughly."]
["With water force suds vigorously between the teeth."]
["The results, a pleasant smile and face for life."]
[The woman smiles broadly.]
[The picture of children on the beach used at the opening of the movie is shown again with text over it. The text reads, "The happiest people are those whose careful health, mental and spiritual habits carry them through to a ripe old age. They are the ones whose laughter rings true."]
[The movie ends.]